british prime minister boris johnson
announces that he is stepping down here
is just part of what he said
it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister and i've agreed with segren
brady the chairman of our back bench mps
that the process of choosing that new
leader should begin now
charlie dagetta is outside the prime
minister's official residence in london
charlie good morning to you uh what was
the atmosphere there like this morning
as the prime minister spoke for one of
the last times
good morning to you tony well aside from
the world press gathered here and
hundreds of protesters outside
this sounded more like a victory speech
even in defeat he outlined his successes
during his almost three years in office
which included the vaccine rollouts and
uh and the support for the war in
ukraine he said he was saddened that he
couldn't finish his full term
however he said that he would remain in
office until a new leader is chosen if
that's the case that may take all the
way to autumn to the fall
several influential leaders in the
conservative party say that isn't going
to work he needs to go now
now this resignation this step down all
follows a series of scandals including
being caught what appeared to be a lie
earlier this week after that
dozens of ministers including cabinet
ministers resigned in protest until he
could not form a manageable government
in his words he said these are his words
he said the herd instinct was powerful
during the speech the protesters i told
you about before they were booing
throughout they were singing bye-bye
baby changing the words to bye-bye boris
even
as the prime minister was speaking as he
said
the headline we're going to see
everywhere as he steps down in his own
words dems to breaks nate
dims the breaks charlie dagger in london
thank you